and a check for 13.8 million dollars
your tax dollars to help Marshall
University build a baseball stadium now
we learn most of that cash the state
received to fight covet and getting
Congress to cut standings getting harder
these days the only thing that we've
been trimming are our resumes we sent
out money for pandemic hell but don't
hesitate to go spoil yourself is your
municipal golf course in need of a
spritz do you want a stadium do you not
exist can you not even afford to put air
in your balls pick up the phone and put
in a call to uncle sugar
sugar
sending cash to the entire nation Uncle
s in the tab to the Next Generation all
is right in the world when you're
reading the bladder and seated Kennedy's
Institute is underwater sure this cash
was four less people dead but at least
we finally found a way to pay a debt how
could you've known when you borrowed for
that fancy degree the gender studies
companies would not be hiring you signed
your name and said you'd pay them one
way or another
don't they know your dad's creepy
Brothers Uncle Sugar Sugar
[Music]
sending cash to the entire nation Uncle
sugar
[Music]
send the tab to the Next Generation
what's the greatest civilization the
world has ever seen though not
everything they did was done impeccably
every few decades their dollars cut in
half from the looks of this they also
worshiped golden cats and when a
pandemic came and times got hard they
gave cash to First Responders of Miss
Park cars voted themselves money
borrowed abroad
how did it end
s and the cash to the entire nation
Uncle sugar
sugar
finally ran out of Next Generation Uncle